let's now move on to the issue of
corruption the number two issue we have
to look at with Trump's immigration ban
from majority Muslim nations is is it
corrupt question that has never been
more important in terms of the u.s.
presidency that in the trump era just as
interesting as the countries included on
the list
seven countries are the countries not
included let's take a look at a map
first before we get into this you'll
notice that not included are Egypt for
example oh I don't know Saudi Arabia for
example the United Arab Emirates Turkey
etc a total coincidence that many of
these countries are ones that Donald
Trump has done business with if you
believe in the concept of a Muslim
majority nation immigration ban how on
earth you justify not putting Saudi
Arabia on that list the a primary source
of 9/11 terrorists hijackers and to
understand the Trump Muslim ban list you
have to also understand the we've got
oil list you've got to understand that
we do business with Trump list many of
these countries have some combination of
oil past business dealings with Donald
Trump or the possibility of business
dealings with Trump let's put up the
table and I'll describe there's a few
sections here we've got three columns is
the country on Trump's Muslim ban list
has there been have there been people
from those countries involved in attacks
on US soil and have these countries done
business or consider doing business with
Donald Trump you'll notice that Iraq
Iran Libya Somalia Sudan Syria and Yemen
are on Trump's list yet none of those
countries have had people involved in
attacks on US soil and none of those
countries have had or considered doing
business with Donald Trump then though
we get to Saudi Arabia Egypt Lebanon in
the United Arab Emirates which are not
on the list have all had terrorists
involved in attacks on US soil and two
of those Saudi Arabia and Egypt have
done business with Donald Trump Trump a
significant commercial interest in
Turkey also Azerbaijan which is not on
the list Trump has
done business there you'll remember that
the terrorists in the 9/11 attacks were
from Saudi Arabia Egypt Lebanon and the
United Arab Emirates none of those four
countries are on the list
Trump has explored developing properties
in Dubai the United Arab Emirates is of
course not on the list has had Nationals
participate in terrorist attacks on US
soil and then Saudi Arabia is
particularly interesting because they
are one of the most oppressive
oppressive regimes in the world
partially because of you know we know
Donald Trump registered eight companies
in Saudi Arabia during the presidential
election during an August 21st rally
Trump the same day Trump created four of
those corporations he talked about how
well he gets along with Saudi Arabia
earlier this year Trump said on Fox News
he would want to protect Saudi Arabia
Trump's seven country ban pad and this
is so key would have blocked zero of the
1919 hijackers I think it's really just
appealing to his base too because I
think most people on the right wing get
a sense that those from Iraq Iran Syria
aren't people that they're going to be
compatible with but when it comes to I
guess Saudi Arabia they're just fine
with it or they're not educated on the
points that they have corrupting
influences to yeah it's it's a complete
PR optics move it is not a move to keep
America objectively safe and I'll deal
with that a little bit later it does
happen to be a terrible PR stunt with
real people suffering the consequences
and because with Trump everything is
projection everything he accused Hillary
Clinton of is something he's guilty of
himself recall that during the
presidential campaign Trump would often
slam Hillary for accepting money from
Saudi Arabia for the Clinton Foundation
what is more corrupt than saying to keep
America safe were going to ban
immigrants from majority Muslim
countries not Saudi Arabia which was the
main source of 9/11 hijackers and oh by
the way I also do business with them and
oh by the way we have shared oil
interest with Saudi Arabia absolute and
total kleptocratic Oleg our kacal crony
capitalist corruption absolutely
despicable I'm thrilled that blue apron
continues to sponsor the David Pakman
show
I've been cooking with blue apron off
and on now
for several months and I've talked about
the problem of food deserts very often
on the show and not only can blue apron
be delivered to 99% of the continental
US blue apron can be delivered to ninety
nine and a half percent of food deserts
and because blue apron ships you the
exact amount of each ingredient that a
recipe requires it reduces food waste
and you don't end up with one green
onion or half a cabbage that you don't
know what to do with and it ends up in
the trash
all too often some of the meals
available this month include mushroom
and chipotle pepper enchiladas with lime
sour cream as well as I made this one a
couple of weeks ago and it came out
really great spicy shrimp and Korean
rice cakes with cabbage you can get your
first three meals for free and get free
shipping by going to blue apron comm
slash Pakman when you do that you
support blue apron and you support the
David Pakman show blue apron dot-com
slash Pakman PA que ma n it is a better
way to cook